[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
émission politique hebdomadaire
au sommaire comment faire voter les
jeunes à moins de deux mois de
l'élection présidentielle
63% des 18-30 ans se disent intéressés
par la campagne et moins de la moitié
affirment qu'ils iront voter au premier
tour selon un baromètre opinionway
comment réconcilier les jeunes avec les
urnes comment les candidats tentent ils
de les séduire c'est le débat de la
semaine jacques de guillebon et alexis
poulain vous livrent ensuite leur actu
du monde d'après mais d'abord après eric
zemmour c'est au tour de valérie
pécresse de faire référence au grand
remplacement lors de son grand meeting
de campagne
une théorie considéré comme complotistes
qui a provoqué des divisions au sein du
camp l air alors sur quoi s'appuient
certains pour donner du crédit à ce
concept décrié
comment at il fini par gagner la droite
républicaine c'est l'habitude des éditos
avec une première question messieurs
selon vous en utilisant l'expression
grand remplacement valérie pécresse at
elle réussi un coup politique pour
draguer l'électorat zemmourien wattel
précipité sa perte
[Musique]
bonjour jacques bonjour alexis alors
avec ce terme de grand remplacement même
s'il ne l'utilisait pas pour valider
cette théorie on peut dire que valérie
pécresse a encore créé la confusion à la
fois dans son camp et n'a pas réussi du
tout aller draguer sur les terres d'eric
zemmour en revanche elle a remis le
sujet au centre de la campagne pendant
la semaine oui moi je pense que le sujet
était déjà au centre de la campagne et
que la droite classique à droite
républicaine avait peur de s'en emparer
le problème c'est la manière dont elle
l'a dit et le peu de conviction qu'on
voit derrière ces propos vert serait
bien qu'on écoute ce qu'elle a dit pour
voir et analyser ça
le sort du monde pourrait s'écrire sans
nous dans dix ans serons nous encore la
septième puissance du monde serons nous
encore une nation souveraine ou un
auxiliaire des états unis un comptoir de
la chine serons-nous une nation unie ou
une nation éclaté
face à ces questions vitales pas de
fatalité ni aux grandes et classement ni
au grand remplacement
alors on a l'impression que valérie
pécresse lit des morceaux de discours
qui ont été écrits par d'autres ils ont
essayé de conquête est né tout ça dans
un discours général en se disant on va
aller parler à la fois à la droite
classique est à la fois à ce qui est
parti vers l'extrême droite sachant
qu'elle a l'impression que qui est
vérifiée d'ailleurs que son électorat
est parti en grande partie fin
l'électorat de fillon de 2017 est parti
en grande partie chez eric zemmour
donc on sent que c'était un coup pour
essayer de rattraper cet électorat là
mais la manière dont ça s'inscrit dans
son discours le fait qu elle même n'en
ai jamais parlé avant de ce terme qu
elles mêmes ou à laquelle on est par les
pour le conspuer
ou un manque de sincérité un manque de
conviction chez elle et en plus ça ne
marche pas parce qu'eric zemmour a déjà
présenté depuis six mois qu'elle arrive
trop tard c'est la première fois qu'on a
un candidat à l'élection présidentielle
qui adoube la théorie du grand
remplacement exil oui bien sûr non
puisque valérie pécresse au contraire
elle dit moi je veux on crée les
républicains dans le camp républicain
dire que cette théorie n'a pas de fond
puisque le problème si on veut revenir
sur cette histoire du remplacement
popularisé par renaud camus il ya deux
choses à la fois le côté du remplacement
qui serait un fait démographique
inévitable des populations mais aussi
dans cette théorie même si renaud camus
s'en défend l'idée qu'il y aurait des
élites remplace 6 c'est à dire qu'ils
auraient des responsables mondialiste
qui ferait en sorte que l'europe
devienne eurabia ou devienne une terre
d'islam volontairement et là on peut
c'est l'aspect culturel pas seulement
démographique qui est à débattre chez l
air comme au front national au
rassemblement national le grand
emplacement c'est niet c'est une théorie
qu'on récuse en disant non on ne peut
pas aller sur ces terres là est le seul
aujourd'hui qui en a fait son cheval de
bataille quasiment c'est eric zemmour et
c'est ça qui fait que je pense que
valérie pécresse est obligé de se
positionner dans nous n'irons pas sur
ces terres là mais néanmoins nous sommes
conscients de ce qu'est aujourd'hui la
migration et l'accueil est l'enjeu
culturel civilisationnel oui mais alors
c'est terrible que le fait d'employés
deux mots disqualifie quelqu'un c'était
pour dire la même chose que ce qu'on
voit grand place manquant si vous
reprenez les propos de renaud camus dont
qui a créé ce terrain en référence au
grand dérangement qui avait vu les
français de france et du canada est
déplacé par les anglais vers le nouvel
os relancer sa la référence à l'origine
c'est à dire c'est le grand déplacement
legrand en placement chez renaud camus
quand il emploie ce terme c'est pour
montrer dans selon ce qu'il dit ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est à dire
qu'il ya une très forte émigration le
sans assimilation ensuite et que sont en
train de s'imposer des nouvelles moeurs
des nouvelles coutumes qui n'était pas
présente en france avant et donc qu'ils
se voient dans le nombre de d'immigrés
qui arrive dans le nombre de prénoms à
consonance hu arabo musulmane soient
africaines qui sont donnés aujourd'hui
c'est ça que vous lui montrez renaud
camus c'est pas une théorie complotiste
chez renault qui est venu de dire il ya
des gens qui ont organisé ça pour
remplacer la population française est de
constater ce qui se passe ensuite qui
est des gens
qu'ils s'en soient emparés pour en faire
une théorie complotiste c'est pas faux
mais là on voit que valérie pécresse
veut essayer de se placer sur le terrain
des migrations oui fortement oui que
comme eric zemmour a poussé loin le
curseur elle est obligée d'employer ce
terme parce que dire il ya trop
d'immigration ça ne résoudrait à
l'oreille de personnes sachant que toute
la droite est à peu près déjà convaincu
de sa donc l effet de faire ce coup là
tout en assumant pas le mot qu'elle a
prononcée elle même que quelqu'un
d'autre a écrit pour elle ni grand
déclassement migrants remplacement
surtout c'est ce fourre-tout en fait
l'idée derrière ces deux thèmes un grand
déclassement grand remplacement c'est
quand même le déclinisme l'idée que la
france va mal qu'on est qu on a eu nos
belles heures derrière et que cette
nation française finalement n'a pas
d'avenir ou un avenir coincé entre l'
empire américain empire chinois et une
europe dont on ne sait pas si elle va
devenir fédéralistes ou qui empêcherait
la survenue de champion français etc
avec bien sûr l'idée que la migration 1
n'a fait que se multiplier ces dernières
années et que l'intégration enfin la
façon dont on fait nation dont on
intègre les populations immigrées s'est
bloqué ou du moins ne fonctionne plus
comme elle a pu le faire auparavant le
seul problème dans cette idée du grand
emplacement de renaud camus et c'est là
où il joue un jeu à d'un double jeu
puisque lui utilise parfois alors il a
arrêté mais dans les années 2010 l'idée
de génocide à bas bruit l'idée d'un
remplacement d'une population par une
autre quand même quand il veut parler de
remplacement c'est culturel et
civilisationnel oui c'est pas raciale
c'est pas la question n'est pas de
savoir alors si de race qui coexistent
ne parle pas de hiérarchie des races
mais si c'est une théorie racialiste pas
raciste et racialiste oui si vous voulez
mais c'est pas vraiment ça qu'il vient
enfin ce pour lui c'est en quoi la
culture française échangé par les
nouvelles cultures qui arrive c'est pas
la question n'est pas la couleur de peau
de la personne qui a fait c'est surtout
pour lui culture africaine et les
cultures musulmanes qui sont arrivés
frontalement en france dans les 40
dernières années sans qu'on s'en soucie
et sans qu'on prenne le temps d'essayer
les assimilés ou deux de vivre avec elle
et on a vu récemment avec le reportage
fait à roubaix qu'il ya des lieux comme
ça qui existent aujourd'hui en france on
peut pas dire le contraire quand ya pas
d endroit où les gens ne sont pas
obligés de vivre selon des moeurs qui
n'existaient pas ici avant et qui ont
été récemment apporté je pense pas qu'on
puisse se réjouir de ces vers ceux là
qui voit les femmes qui font des poupées
son visage qui voit les petites filles
je pense que vous serez d'accord avec
moi là dessus et c'est ça je pense que
renaud camus veut dénoncer est
évidemment une partie de l'extrême
droite mais renaud camus n'est pas un
homme politique lui-même a écrit ça
skiable qu'il aime c'est comment les
alertes se retrouve face à ce terme là
et comment ils sont obligés de le
reprendre sans vouloir l'assumer c'est à
cause d'eric zemmour qui est comme je le
dis le seul candidat qui ouvertement
prend ces thèmes là ne n'a pas de pudeur
de gazelle vis-à-vis de ces thèmes là et
les utilisent comme un programme le seul
problème la limite de ce programme c'est
que derrière l'idée de la lutte contre
l'idée de remplacement il yal'art
émigration c'est-à-dire relocaliser de
manière non-violente les populations
exogènes puisque j'emploie le terme là
dedans une camus dans leur pays faisant
il faut que les races cohabitent chacun
chez soi et tout ira bien mais c'est
remy gracieux elle est quasiment
impossible à faire et puis comment vous
faites en fait pour dire que quelqu'un
issu d'un couple mixte par exemple il
est français
quand on parle d'immigrés de première
deuxième troisième génération au bout de
la troisième on peut considérer qu'on
ait pris migri qu'on est français quand
même mais au bout de la deuxième donc il
ya tout et tout une question sur la
pureté de la race l'idée de français de
souche qui est difficile en fait à
défendre et qui est impossible à mettre
en place en réalité alors on peut
contrôler les flux migratoires on peut
maintenant se poser la question de quoi
sert l'europe au contrôle des frontières
on peut se poser la question de
l'accueil aussi parlé des mineurs isolés
et plein de thèmes qui sont réelles et
où là il faut des réponses politiques
maintenant sur le fantasme de l'art
émigration ça me paraît être un
programme un peu ce oui mais ça vous
remarquerez que même eric zemmour on n'a
pas parlé de rémunération pour l'instant
c'est pas dans son programme mais c'est
ce qui est derrière
il ya il peut y avoir une autre idée qui
est celle de l'assimilation c'est à dire
de faire de ces gens-là changer de
prénom plus que les français de papier
des français demeure solide et m c'est
pour ça que eric zemmour parle de parle
de prénom mais on peut pas nier que
depuis 30 ans et d'ailleurs avec une
accélération rapide cette année
une très grande part d'enfants qui
naissent en france sont des enfants
soient de couples mixtes soit deux coups
punir et que ça ne fait que monter
depuis 20 ans gré des chiffres comme ça
c'est passé de 10 à à 20 ou 30% en étant
donc on veut dire là dessus qu'il n'ya
ça quelque chose qui change dans la
population française 75% ses deux
parents français les naissances en
france encore aujourd'hui 80 ça devait
être 95% oui bien sûr que et tout comme
la part d'étrangers dans au sein de la
population française augmente depuis les
années 70 ça aussi c'est un fait mais on
est loin d'un grand remplacement on est
sur des échelles de 12 % de population
étrangère en france donc on n'est pas
sûr du 50% après la question culturelle
ça c'est une vraie question est
évidemment qu'il est important de
défendre aussi d'identité alors la
question d'identité à chaque fois c'est
un tabou or qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'identité française il ya des pays qui
n'ont pas ce tabou de l'identité qui au
contraire essaye de savoir ce qu'ils
sont et comment ils existent nous avec
je pense aussi la construction
européenne on a voulu diluer finalement
l'idée d'identité nationale de peur que
les nations face à nouveau la guerre et
on arrive à ce degré zéro finalement de
la réflexion politique oui qu'est ce
qu'on voit chez les républicains ou
valérie pécresse s'est fait taper tiré
dans le dos par ses amis des
républicains elle est allé tout seul au
front là dessus en disant je vais
récupérer cet électorat là non seulement
elle n'a pas récupéré mais en plus elle
risque de perdre une partie de son
électorat précédent et ces derniers amis
aux républicains
place au débat de la semaine elle baude
l'isoloir mais bat le pavé la jeunesse
et l'électorat séduire pour les
candidats campagne sur les réseaux
sociaux applications dédiées soutien
d'influenceurs tous les moyens sont bons
pour la ramener vers les urnes la
jeunesse at elle réellement tourner le
doigt la politique ou seulement à ses
représentants comment sont justement par
jauger une proposition portée par trois
candidats le droit de vote à 16 ans une
solution selon vous pour lutter contre
l'abstention
[Musique]
pour moi c'est la solution la plus bête
qu'on puisse imaginer c'est à dire ça ne
ferait que faire augmenter l'abstention
de d'abaisser le droit de vote à 16 ans
à moins que les gens aient envie de
voter entre 16 et 18 ans puis ensuite
plus du tout jusqu'à 35 ans parce que ce
qu'on constate c'est que voilà mais les
records d'abstention c'est dans le
segment lieu chez les ch et des jeunes
gens ont entre 18 et 30 ans dont kbc ne
ferait pas à free augmenterez le corps
électoral évidemment mécaniquement mais
ferait encore augmenter l'abstention la
question je pense pas qu'elle ait de de
baisser l'âge du vote elle est de
comment intéresser de jeunes citoyens à
la chose politique le problème c'est la
dépolitisation des populations enfin
quand on voit qu'aujourd'hui la jeunesse
se sont moins proches d'un parti ou même
moins connaisseuse des idées politiques
qu'il ya de ça quelques années c'est ça
qui devrait inquiéter c'est pas l'âge
finalement de voter je pense que l'on
peut voter à saison mais si on ne sait
pas ce qu'est la politique si on ne sait
pas ce que sont les idées politiques si
on ne se passe que c'est que le marxisme
la droite la gauche le libéralisme ça
sert à rien donc c'est une question
d'éducation nationale c'est une question
d'instruction c'est une question
d'éducation civique et c'est pas une
question d'âge du vote or qu'est ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans l'école
c'est un abaissement du niveau et c'est
certainement pas l'idée de vouloir faire
des citoyens éclairés qui vont ensuite
voter en connaissance de cause ou se
rapprocher de partie
donnez à votre côté déclinistes
suis parfaitement d'accord avec vous là
dessus j'allais le dire aussi il ya ça
mais il ya aussi et là c'est vous qui à
lille dirigé des rues places et aussi le
fait de l'union européenne qui a enlevé
l'effectivité politique en france c'est
à dire que les jeunes gens et on a
l'impression à tinqueux et beaucoup de
français que le politique français a de
moins en moins d'efficacité de moins en
moins de pouvoir qu'il a tiré à deux
endroits notamment l'union européenne et
notamment on voit aussi même si c'est
pas la politique directement on voit le
poids des gars femmes on voit le poids
des grandes entreprises comme ça qu'ils
ont l'impression qu'ils ont plus de
pouvoir sur la vie des gens
sur les cabinets de conseils 3 milliards
par an dépenser chez mckinsey et
d'autres cabinets de conseil l'état est
rendu incapable par les dirigeants
actuels qui préfèrent payer des
entreprises privées étrangères plutôt
que d'investir dans des fonctionnaires
qui savent faire travailler la machine
d'état donc c'est aussi une volonté de
déposséder une volonté aussi anti
souveraine qui est en train qui est à
l'oeuvre qui est à la manoeuvre mais
au-delà de ça je pense que il ya
l'instruction certes il ya aussi après
le côté glamour enfin la très qu'on peut
avoir à la chose politique et là on voit
des responsables politiques des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
qui ne font pas rêver qu'ils vont avoir
beaucoup de mal à emmener une dynamique
de jeunesse alors il ya quelques
exceptions on peut regarder eric zemmour
notamment qui a réussi à attirer
beaucoup de jeunes sont loin mais je
crois que pittsburgh soit encore plus
bas chez les jeunes beaucoup plus bas
que marine le pen beaucoup il va que
jean luc mélenchon et emmanuel macron
mais il a réussi quand même en
remportant de nulle part avoir une
france jeune assez large
comparé à d'autres partis qui vont avoir
du mal à élever aussi on pouvait
s'attendre ce qui est davantage de
jeunes qui sont
conscientes des enjeux climatiques qui
pourraient voter naturellement pour les
écolos c'est pas du tout le cas et puis
alors le ps alors là c'est la bérézina
je pense que les jeunes avec hidalgo je
ne sais même pas si ce mouvement existe
j'ose imaginer que oui mais je ne sais
pas combien ils sont a prévu ce qui est
frappant et peut-être qu'on peut s'en
réjouir paradoxalement c'est que la
génération des baby boomers des soixante
huitards était ultra politisé ultra
politisé sans doute pour des mauvaises
raisons aussi moi je suis pas malheureux
que la jeunesse est arrêté de vénérer
che guevara et fidel castro les khmers
rouges ou mao en fait celle là dessus et
nous kennedy où kennedy d'une autre
façon et un certain progrès le suivait
et qui les gens qui sont allés voter
pour françois mitterrand en 81 qui
étaient surtout des jeunes ne sont pas
allés voter parce que mitterrand était
sexy c'est pas vrai sur les voter parce
qu'il y avait un mouvement de gauche qui
étaient partis 68 et qui aboutit et
jusqu'à lui qu'il avait été assez habile
pour rassembler donc il ya eu cette
grande période par rapport à laquelle on
juge qui est la période des années 70
début 80 où les gens étaient extrêmement
politisée parce que c'était encore lire
des vidéos et notamment communiste qui
se sont écroulées comme on le sait avec
le muret dans les années 90 et qui n'ont
pas été remplacés fa qui ont été
remplacés par d'autres idéologies mais
qui sont moins directement politique
comme vous le disiez et la question
écologique de l'ecobank société qui va
toucher les jeunes gens mais ça se
traduit pas par un vote en tout cas pas
par un vote national puisque se disent
que peut faire yannick jadot avec ses
petits bras avec ses gros bras peut-être
mais en tant que président d'un parti
vert français alors que c'est le monde
qui est en train de s'écrouler que c'est
la banquise et non au terme d'un état on
peut pas faire grand chose mais on voit
qu'il ya des ruptures des lignes de
fortes politiques par exemple sur le
nucléaire là c'est quelque chose qui
redéfinit les cartes la jeunesse va être
conscientes de ce type d'enjeu après
c'est vrai que sur d'autres sujets on
voit bien qu'il ya de la dépolitisation
au croissante quant on voit par exemple
la république en marche qui utilise un
gouvernement d'influenceurs marlène
schiappa qui invite les influences euse
pour parler du droit des femmes
gabriella talent porte parole du
gouvernement qui avait là aussi des
émissions avec des influenceurs youtube
et puis le président des influenceurs
lui-même qui invite max l'ail et carlito
pour rigoler à l'elysée faire des
roulades sur la pelouse de du palais
présidentiel tout ça c'est des
opérations de communication c'est pas de
la politique qu'ils sont là simplement
pour dire regardez les jeunes vous
intéressez pas la politique mais nous on
parle à vos idoles à ce qu'ils font les
vidéos que vous regardez donc on doit
être cool donc voté pour nous mais on
est vraiment dans le degré zéro encore
une fois de la politique et on peut voir
ça s'étend à tout le monde parce que
jean luc mélenchon lui-même est devenu
un tic toc heures depuis quelques temps
une marine le pen aussi eric zemmour au
cyclisme
parle sur les réseaux enfin une armée de
jeunes gens sur les réseaux pour laver
le cerveau des autres et les relie donc
c'est nommé ce qui est drôle c'est que
ça crée une bulle comme ça qui ne se
traduise jamais jusqu'à présent aravot
et au contraire par une chute du vote
dans le sens où on peut imaginer que ces
jeunes gens sont amusés de voir ce
spectacle mais ne vois pas le rapport
avec leur vie politique ni même avec le
fait d'aller voter non mais c'est parce
que c'est la société du spectacle c'est
absolument ça c'est que le politique est
devenue un théâtre de guignol un théâtre
du pouvoir mais pas le lieu du pouvoir
et je pense que les gens sont très
conscients y compris les jeunes donc
c'est rigolo de voir eric zemmour faire
un strike au bowling sur tik tok marine
le pen décrocher son chat du sapin de
noël jean luc mélenchon voire sont les
fraises mais ça ne sert à rien alors les
politiques se rassure en disant qu'il
parle à une un public difficile à
atteindre potentiellement mais c'est
dans les meetings c'est dans la
confrontation c'est dans les mouvements
de jeunesse aussi qu'on va avoir à
politiser ces jeunes électeurs qui vont
ensuite parlé politisé il y avait les
syndicats typiquement qui faisait ce
rôle-là l'unef et d'autre l'uni qui
avaient ce rôle là aujourd'hui c'est
pareil même ces syndicats de jeunesse
syndicats étudiants sont en crise on le
voit avec l'unef particulièrement mais
et c'est donc toute la mécanique de
politisation alors vous le déplorez en
tant que c'était 68 et que ça se faisait
du côté des trotskistes dans les années
soixante dix mais il faut bien un moment
avoir affaire se frotter aux idées
politiques et pour enclencher une
réflexion sur ce que c'est que le
devenir citoyen tout à fait d'accord et
on voit que tous les tous les essais de
repos l'utilisation des jeunes qui ont
été jetées pas de nuit debout par
exemple l'époque qui avait créé place
publique ensuite ou même la primaire
populaire qui est d'apporter christiane
taubira à la tête enfin une candidate
qui est organisée par des jeunes gens
qui n'accouche pour l'instant de rien un
fils yann taubira stagne dans les
sondages on sait pas s'il va se
présenter réellement où chaque fois ce
sont des essais sympathique de vaud
repolitisation mais qui sont des coups
d'épée dans l'eau ouais et qui n'ont
jamais accouché pour l'instant de rien
on voit pas de mouvements de jeunes qui
auraient porté
non un candidat aux nues y compris des
mouvements de protestation comme les
gilet jaune vous aviez plutôt les grands
parents inquiets pour leurs petits
enfants ou les parents mais très peu de
jeunes finalement ou alors des jeunes en
formation mais c'était pas non plus un
mouvement de jeunesse et là on les
cherche effectivement les mouvements de
jeunesse pour le plan politique oui je
pense que c'est quelque chose mais c'est
quelque chose qui est très commun à tout
l'occident et on n'aide pas les plus mal
lotis si on veut se rassurer c'est à
dire qu'on a pas eu pour l'instant de
trump encore on on n'a pas eu de beppe
grillo de selvini commis en italie c'est
à dire que la politique spectaculaire
n'est pas encore totalement achevée en
france et il reste encore des enjeux
politiques qui s'imposent au delà des
personnages clown qui se présenteraient
malheureusement je crois qu'avec cette
campagne-là et des personnages comme
emmanuel macron qui incarne le vide de
la pensée politique ou eric zemmour
inquiets le clown potentiellement trump
heist on peut y arriver très facilement
direction le monde d'après alexis poule
a et jacques de guillebon vous apportent
leur éclairage chaque semaine sur une
information qui pourrait faire
l'actualité politique de demain
commençons par vous alexis selon vous
quelles infos mérite cette semaine un
coup de projecteur
alors l'info qui selon moi mérité le
coup de projecteur cette semaine c'est
le ralliement surprise de ségolène royal
à la candidature de jean-luc mélenchon
ségolène royal candidate à l'élection
présidentielle malheureuse en 2007
ensuite elle a eu cette carrière
d'ambassadrice des pôles etc mais elle
quitte sa famille politique le parti
socialiste pour dire finalement le mieux
placé dans les sondages le mieux placé
aussi dans la dynamique de gauche
aujourd'hui actuellement c'est jean luc
mélenchon elle appelle même anne hidalgo
a retiré sa candidature en disant qu'il
faut maintenant faire l'union derrière
le candidat le mieux placé c'est assez
étonnant quand même de voir ce soutien
là de ségolène royal à jean luc
mélenchon alors il vient justement
comment est-ce qu'elle le soutient c'est
à dire que c'est juste une candidature
utile qu'elle veut soutenir ou c'est sur
les idées lequel pense qu'il est le
meilleur c'est un peu des deux en disant
qu'aujourd'hui la gauche est là et que
c'est la candidature utile et qu' ils
défendent des idées de social-démocratie
d'une certaine façon même si lui s'en
défend et une candidature écolo
également oui enfin c'était mieux dans
quel emile 15 ans à s'en apercevoir donc
jean luc mélenchon a pas tellement
changé le programme depuis mai ségolène
royal et elle-même peut-être assez
versatile oui puisqu'elle était prête à
soutenir valérie pécresse je crois un
moment que ça peut aller très loin les
soutiens de ségolène royal mail a en
tout cas c'est un clou de plus sur le
cercueil de la campagne d'anne hidalgo
j'ai l'impression de mon côté je
voudrais parler d'un autre d'autres
ralliements mais à l'extrême opposé
l'échiquier politique qui sont tous ces
ralliements de cadres du rnd à eric
zemmour et ce qui est fascinant c'est
l'impression de silence que donne marine
le pen à ce sujet là on a l'impression
qu'elle se fait dépouiller de tous les
cadres en vue de son parti ait eu jérôme
rivière yalu gilbert collard maintenant
nicolas bay qui était donc
vrais anciens du parti allait aussi
ravier et non seulement elle ne dirait
mon impression qu elle a calé heureuse
de les pousser vers la sortie elle a eu
une image assez méchantes sur la limace
à propos de nicolas bay en disant qu'il
fallait que les limaces keats le parti
parce que les limaces non seulement
étaient lentes mais en plus poisseuse
voilà qui fait enfin qu'elle se
débarrasse et ils sont tous en train de
partir mais elle même qui n'est plus
président du ra ce moment national
d'ailleurs pour l'instant uniquement
candidate dans la pression qu'elle
qu'elle s'en moque quel est au dessus de
ça et que peu lui importe ce qui restera
du versant le national après cette
élection donc soit elle se dit qu'elle
est certaine de gagner cette élection et
qu'elle sera président de la république
française et que peu lui chaut le sort
de ces de ces traîtres fa vous de ces
ralliés soit
soit quelque chose que je ne comprends
pas ou alors peut-être qu elle en train
de préparer des ralliements incroyable
lie nos deux façons soit encore une fois
comme c'est souvent le cas au réseau
national il ya quelques personnes autour
d'elle qui font un nettoyage complet et
qui vire tout ce qui n'est pas à la
botte de la patronne enfin elle peut pas
imaginer gagner une élection
présidentielle sans équipe c'est ça qui
est assez étonnant c'est à dire que
chaque cadre qui part c'est un ministre
aussi qui ne reviendra pas donc ça
paraît compliqué da déjà d'enclencher
une dynamique et de se rassurer alors
peut-être qu'il est dans la méthode
cauet qu'elle se dit que tout va bien
dans les sondages que finalement elle
n'a même pas besoin de faire campagne
elle n'était pas mercredi à l'invitation
de la ruralité pour parler de ruralité
qu'un thème quand même centrale du ratio
national et elle se dit bah je liquide
le parti toutes affaires cessantes en
dix ans c'est ma dernière campagne et
après ça ciao débrouillez vous avec ce
qui restera de cette droite là on va
voir ce qui va se passer dans les
semaines qui viennent en tout cas avec
plaisir et bientôt alexis bientôt
jacques c'est la fin du duel des éditos
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site rt france point tv
et en podcast sur toutes les plateformes
vous pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag
dde à la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau duel des éditos
[Musique]